um first of all we had a really great
poster session yesterday uh thank you to
all the students who gave questions
yesterday the discussions were great
students wouldn't stop talking we
literally could not get them to leave
yeah so I hope this afternoons is going
to be just as good if not better
um I hope everyone will attend the
blisters this afternoon another thing I
wanted to say was uh as we mentioned um
NSF is supporting this workshop and as
part of that uh we have a survey that we
would like everyone to fill out
um just about what you came away with
from this Workshop how it was good how
it could be better
um yes that'll you'll get an email about
that uh hopefully soon and then please
everyone fill that fill that out as soon
as you can uh okay so it's my great
pleasure to introduce our uh our our
keynote speaker today Todd Coleman
um from Stanford who needs no further
introduction please take it away thank
you so much
and a lot of folks uh got a lot of old
friends here haven't seen in a while so
I thought the first thing I do is I'll
show you how things have changed for his
perhaps since the last time I've seen
you so on the left is my son Camden he's
six years old and on the right is my
daughter Lila she's 20 months old yes
yes so uh with that you know I thought I
would do is kind of tell you guys
um the path that I took towards thinking
about the math problem that they were
going with and where it started is when
I was an assistant professor at the
University of Illinois and I had done a
postdoc in Neuroscience so I was
interested in playing around with some
type of application that involved
neuroscience and some fun engineering
and I stumbled upon a way this is around
like 2006 the way people were thinking
about brain computer interfaces where
you you know instrument someone with a
shower cap EEG recording brain waves and
people were trying to do very basic
things like control the system to move a
cursor to the left or to move a cursor
on the right and the essence of how they
thought about the problem statistically
is imagine if there's a binary signal
imagine left or imagine right we record
these waveforms uh the EEG and I
basically just updated posterior
distribution about this and you know I
needed to decode it and maybe move to
the left or the right
so a little bit about the basics of how
this works is you can imagine that um
the measurement of EEG it's a signal Y
and uh there's some Matrix a which
basically Maps the dipoles which are the
little yellow things that you see it
Maps them to the actual recordings That
You observe and obviously there's
measurement noise and if we think about
some of the basic physiology we know for
instance related to movement and a
certain frequency band called the beta
band or these cortical rhythms right and
so you can take a look at these
underlying rhythms and one of the things
that we um we know uh quite well is that
when you imagine squeezing your left
hand versus when you imagine squeezing
the right hand the uh the spatial
patterns Associated where the voltages
are larger magnitude versus small they
change because of uh there's a
somatotopic representation of our brain
when we try to imagine you know doing
something to the left versus something
to the right so if you have the spatial
information you can imagine without
going into a lot of details how you
might be able to to you know build a
measurement model and then from which uh
do basic uh types of Beijing in
inference so this was the essence of how
everyone was uh was thinking about this
problem was basically binary signal we
take advantage of the somatotopic
mapping in the brain and then we
basically just update a posterior
distribution and then you move the
cursor to the left or the right on the
screen
but the epiphery that we had is that
there's something about this that didn't
feel right because the way uh you know
brain computer interface maybe really
should work is uh this interconnection
uh between the human and the computer
and it should be bi-directional in
nature as compared to just this one shot
open loop you imagine something and we
decode and the analogy I like to give as
I remember when I was in high school the
first car I got was a 1983 Honda Accord
and I had an alignment problem and what
was interesting is despite the fact
there was an alignment problem I could
still drive the car because if you let
it go straight it starts to Veer to the
left but I see it's veering to the left
and I provide corrective feedback and
yet I can still drive the car to spike
that so the high level idea that came to
my mind is that where is this notion of
feedback and where is this sequential
notion of operation of this device as
compared to a sequence of open loop
types of uh control paradigms so what we
got interested in formulating was
something that involved a little bit of
ideas for maybe control theory but
there's posterior to distribution so
it's kind of the intersection of control
theory information Theory and the idea
is a team decision Theory and so
imagine there's something that's
continuous value that I that that's my
high level goal that I'm trying to
achieve and that's like this number W
that lies on the zero one interval and
I'm sequentially signaling to the
computer and I'm signaling with this
signal X and this is the signal for
instance that's in my brain either
imagining squeezing my left hand or I'm
imagining squeezing my right hand and
then Y is just like what we showed
before the Y for the voltages associated
with the shower cap that I have on my
head recorded with the EEG and the the
formulation I wanted to come up with was
the computer is giving me some type of
feedback right and so it's kind of like
when you're driving your car that's
misaligned you see the trajectory of the
car you steering one way and so then the
the subsequent control signal the x of T
that you give is in some sense a
corrective signal to try to help steer
it and so the high level idea that came
in my mind is how can I formulate this
just for starters overly simplistic and
oh and by the way the computer what is
it sequentially doing well what came to
my mind is that ultimately we want the
computer to accomplish the high level
goal of the human so let's suppose that
the computer is maintaining some
probability distribution uh that
reflects uh its belief over what's
happening given everything it's seen so
far so that's what Z time T is
so we can think about this uh from you
know team decision decision Theory which
is basically optimal control but now
when we have multiple agents One agent
being the human and one being a computer
so imagine I'm trying to optimize
something I'm trying to maximize uh some
accumulation of rewards and I want to
obey the principles of causality meaning
that uh uh the next signal that I give
at time T is a function of the high
level goal that I have which is W as
well as all the feedback that the that
the computer has given me which now I'm
just representing is all the Y's up
until time T minus one and then
obviously the the the the belief that
the computer makes a Time T is a
function of just the things that it saw
Will wise up until time T So This is
actually a team decision problem with
non-classical information structure
people remember things like with the
wits and housing problem or or things
along these lines this fits that
um and so a thought there's another
thing came in mind is okay so what's the
reward function be what do I want to
maximize well ideally what I would like
is I would like the computer
I'd like its belief about the message to
be as narrow as possible ideally to
converge towards a point mass at the
message point and so one way to think
about this is let's make this a
maximization of the mutual information
so suppose a disease is a posterior
distribution so if I if I let the reward
function be the um the the um basically
the RN derivative of the posterior time
T relative to T minus one then when I
accumulate that over time what I end up
with is the mutual information right
because if you think about this
um foreign
to some capital T of the log of so what
I'm saying is basically the by D Pi T by
T minus 1 evaluated at w you know all
this means didactically suppose that
these things had densities right and
this is the log of the density of w
um from the Y's up until time t
divided by the density Y is up until
time T minus one right uh you know
evaluated W right
likewise here
notice what's going to happen is that
all what's going to be left ultimately
this is just going to become the
posterior
wise up until time key divided by the
prior
right
so that's exactly what this becomes
because these guys end up in a numerator
and a denominator from T going from 2 to
time T minus one and when you take the
expected value you get the mutual
information okay so uh so it should be
clear to everyone that the expected
value of this quantity is the mutual
information so uh so if I set up my
reward function that way then I end up
with the mutual information so I'm here
at UC Berkeley so I want to give a shout
out to wall Ron and Mariah because when
I was looking at this problem there was
this 1983 paper by wall Runner variety
and to my students by the way I've got
four students here stand up Andrew Alice
Serena tomage right so of course
students from the other side of the day
um uh there's just a Learning lesson to
them so uh we're here uh Berkeley
territory so these are two uh legendary
figures at Berkeley and at this really
interesting paper in 1983 called optimal
calls coding decoding problems and so
you have a you know noisy channel right
here
you have an old encoder that's taking
causal information from all the previous
whys so here they're assuming that
there's a Markov Source that's being
given to you but mine is a Markov Source
because I can just let w
he's just W right but W is Markov
because you can index it over time but
it's always the same W and then you have
this uh Receiver right here that's
operating in this way and in our example
um these updates right these Z's
remember I want them to be posterior
distributions and so one of the things
that they talked about is that they're
always exists in optimal encoder that
operates on just um the most recent
input of the Markov source and the most
recent piece of feedback from the
decoder okay so uh uh so this began to
be interesting and so I want to map this
back to our problem and so sort of
building upon wall around a variety I
can now constrain the class of encoders
and decoders to have this type of
structure
um
and the decoder as I alluded to it's
quite obvious and it and it turns out uh
it's kind of cute but remember for that
Mutual information objective that I have
what I can show is that there's all this
kale Divergent stuff that occurs and the
optimal decoding scheme is exactly what
you thought it would be it ends up being
just a posterior update right so the
optimal uh zetone T given everything so
far is literally just Bayes roll okay so
the 64 000 question is how should the
encoder behave and so uh it turns out if
we stand back and we think about this if
our objective is to maximize Mutual
information and notice that this you
know I'm assuming that this noisy
channel is a uh um is a you know
memoryless Channel then we know that the
mutual information is upper bounded uh
uh uh uh by the capacity moreover we
know exactly the if and only of
conditions and the two if and only if
conditions or that the next signal to
the m to the channel should be the
capacity achieving distribution of a
One-Shot use of the channel but more
importantly a Time T the next signal
should be statistically they're trying
to serve everything the decoder has seen
so far so this is in standard cover and
Thomas when you take the information
with your class when you look at other
capacities Unchained unchanged with
feedback
so if we look about an example of a Bic
suppose as I alluded to before X is just
imagining left or imagining right and uh
I remember this is sort of what our ply
given X looks like and you can without a
loss of generality you can assume that
that's a BSC because there's symmetry so
it turns out that horstein thought about
this problem way back in 1963 and then
shayavits and fader in 2011 uh so
horsing came up with the scheme but he
didn't prove that it actually achieved
capacity but this was proved by shavitz
and fader in 2011 and in fact they
generalized it to an arbitrary uh
um a memoryless channel and so what if
we focus on the BSC for a minute the
first thing you do is you take the
posterior density which is pi T minus
one and you compute it CDF you see this
is this function evaluated at w and it's
an integral from 0 to W so this is the
CDF of the posterior distribution so and
then basically what I do is I take the
CDF of the posterior distribution and I
evaluate it at w
okay so I'm just uh taking the the
posterior distribution and evaluating it
at the message point and then all I'm
going to do is I'm going to compare that
uh to a threshold of 0.5
and if you're less than 0.5 I signal
left and if you're greater than 0.5 I
signal right okay
is that sort of clear for everyone and
what I want you to appreciate why this
is achieving oh why this is at least
maximizing Mutual information is because
notice what I'm doing is so you see s at
time T minus one is the CDF of the
posterior distribution and then I Define
WT uh to just shove in W into that
object right so notice what I'm doing is
I'm shoving a random variable into its
own CDF do you guys remember in your
undergraduate probability clients that
you either teach or you talk that when
you shove a random variable into its own
CDF the output is always uniform zero
one so irrespective of what the previous
y's were this is always uniform zero one
so notice the right hand side is not
depending upon the Y's up until time T
minus one so this is always uniform and
moreover is statistically independent of
all the past y's and then literally all
I do is I shove it into this object and
all this is doing is this is just
shaping this is shaping to make sure
that X is one half one half which is
capacity achieving for the BSC so this
part is easy this is just a quantizer
right that's shaping it so that it has
the optimal distribution for the
One-Shot use of the channel but more
importantly we're making sure that it's
statistically independent of everything
the decoder has seen so far right this
is literally undergrad probability stuff
right so clearly this is maximizing
Mutual information in particular at
every time T this is exactly the
capacity times T the aggregate Mutual
information and Shay of its and fader
also show that this actually also
achieves capacity the posterior is
Contracting at an exponential rate right
where there's a volume of probability
approximately one that has length two to
the minus NC
so that's nice uh so the question
becomes does this exactly map to the the
problem with human computer interfaces
that I was interested in and I argue no
because uh human cannot accumulate all
the past uh you know measurements that
the decoder has you know the the channel
has seen as a human you're going to give
the human all the past EEG waveforms and
have the human figure out what to do
next well no what should be nice is
maybe something that looks like this and
so the idea is that the decoder
as uh uh all the past wise and then what
it does is it provides some type of
query to the human that is simply as
simple as possible so the human can just
maybe perform a very simple comparison
right so remember humans you know we
have a limited sensory capabilities
right so you want to minimize the
question that we asked them so the
question becomes can we sort of map this
to this and notice I put the dashed
lines because you see this is everything
that wise up until T minus one which is
encoded in this posterior distribution
and so this aggregate box is almost like
the encoder with feedback but part of it
is the computer and part of it is the
human and so I can formulate it this way
and say well let me optimize over all
these functions Tau and I want to have a
query point which perhaps is also a
number on the zero one line and so the
only thing I'm given to the human is a
number on the zero one line he has his
own intended number on the zero one line
and maybe he performs a very simple
comparison to Signal can we do that and
it turns out that the answer is yes and
it turns out that there's a one-to-one
correspondence between between the
original way where what signaling is all
the past wise and a simpler scheme where
what I do is I if I'm the computer I
have the posterior distribution and I
calculate the median of the posterior
which is a simple number on the zero one
line and all the human does is they just
do a very simple comparison they
basically just do
get to query uh exceeds the message then
I signal left and I have to query you
know you know if the yeah on the other
hand I signal one and this is a well
this is this is you know the Dynamics of
these are in one-to-one correspondence
to each other but hopefully what you can
appreciate is this is something more
meaningful to a human well Lisa you have
a question
it turns out these are exactly
mathematically the same thing this
actually goes back to a horse you need
this 1963 paper that shows this yeah
yeah yeah so for this yeah for the so
for the for the BSC this is a one-on-one
correspondence because if you think
about this what is the median the median
is the point for which half the
posterior probabilities to the left and
half the posterior probabilities to the
right yeah yeah so
well you see the key point I
deliberately want to engineer something
that looks like this because a human you
want to minimize the query information
you're giving to the human so we
actually did some fun things with this
so uh you know this is like around 2011
we published a paper feedback
information theoretic approach to the
design and brain computer interfaces so
what we did you guys know this for
information Theory class remember
Shannon in his original paper he was
interested in the statistics of the
English language it's kind of funny
because that's the essence of what chat
GPT is right well it's building a good
predictive distribution right right so
all I'm doing right here is I'm
basically doing what Shannon did his
original paper and I'm building like a a
Markov model of the of the of the
English language so imagine that the
message point is a very long sentence
that someone is trying to convey right
and so as you guys know I can I can put
that as one-on-one correspondence with a
point in the zero one line where what I
do is I make the first sentence
uh uh think about like Shannon Shannon
Elias coding right so the the you know
the the length of this interval
corresponds to the probability right CCT
takes on a lot of length and Z takes on
not that much and then inside of here
this now is the conditional distribution
given that the first character was T
yada yada and so we basically built this
as you see as you go into a longer and
longer sentence that's a longer and
longer sequence so the width is
beginning smaller and smaller so
ultimately it's like an infinitesimal
point that I have in my head that I'm
trying to convey and so what we're
always doing is we're always making this
basically the median of the posterior
before any information this is literally
just the point one half right and I'm
comparing and then what I do is I warp
the display
so that the median is always at one half
so I'm zooming in on some areas so the
median is always at one half and as I
can and yeah this is this is an instance
of us really signaling across a BSC with
our brain computer interface
and what we're doing is we're uh warping
with the posterior distribution so that
this is always one half and you see the
effect is that you start to zoom in and
you see more and more you're zooming in
on T H has a lot of probability and over
time you end up spelling the the black
cat jumped over the lazy dog or whatever
the you know the famous sentences uh so
another instance of what we did with
this uh back when we were over the corn
fields of Illinois we got interested in
actually doing something crazy like um
trying to specify a smooth path and
we're thinking imagine if we could fly
remote control airplane over the
cornfields of Illinois so the first step
we wanted to do is represent that as a
sequence of small little Arc lengths you
can think about a path as a sequence of
Arc lengths and assume that there's a
finite number of those Arc lengths so
again it's just a sequence of things
that are finite in nature and so I can
encode and actually what we ended up
using I don't know if I remember is Tom
Culver's paper from the 1970s called
enumerative Source coding so we're
building upon Culver's enumerative
Source coding here and so now what
happens is the decoder has a posterior
distribution and so right now it's flat
it's uniform and so the decoder provides
a query and so that queries some number
on the zero one line
and so that corresponds to a path so we
have our desired path which is in green
and then we have the blue path which is
the query and how we're using covers a
numerative source coding is that one of
the things that he shows is if you have
this lexicographic type of structure
that you can you can maintain kind of
orientation and whatnot right so we're
taking advantage of that and so um all
you have to do to complete because
remember all you have to do is you take
a look at the median and you say or to
the are you less than or greater than
the median but now I have a sequence of
Arc lengths so how do I do a comparison
well cover a numerative source coding
you can maintain that by looking at the
first location where the two sequences
differ and then basically if it's
counterclockwise that means imagine left
if it's clockwise it means imagine right
so I sequentially do this
so now the the posterior District the
posterior distribution gets updated from
the brain waves in my head and so now it
calculates the new median of the
posterior distribution which is this red
vertical line it goes through this
lookup table and this point corresponds
to that path right there so then it
shows this blue path on the screen keep
in mind the only thing that's on the
screen is the blue stuff the green stuff
is in my mind and I'm looking at the
first location where they differ and I
signal uh if it's clockwise or
counterclockwise and over time the
posterior distribution is beginning to
contract and moreover the my true path
as well as the path that's being shown
are overlapping more and more and not
until later and Ladder parts so they
disagree
so we actually you know did some fun
things with like Google Earth and built
a BCI Paradigm and so this is an
instance of me spelling this with my EEG
uh back over to San Diego and I was on
my way to give a talk at Princeton uh
actually and so I specified a path from
San Diego to Princeton as you can see
here and uh we did some other fun things
with this as I alluded to our real hope
for doing this was to actually fly like
a UAV over the corn fields and so we
collaborated with some aerospace
engineers and uh we were able to do this
and so here's a little video uh you can
see uh I see this is just with the brain
waves and he is just um
specifying that path and here's the
plane flying and it's sequentially
flying over the corn fields of Illinois
uh one other thing that's nice about
this Paradigm is if you notice where the
paths differ it ends up being further
and further parts of the path that gives
time for the airplane to have momentum
to fly so there's another kind of extra
benefit of the Dynamics that just comes
out of this it's just luck to be honest
so so how does this relate to the the
title of my talk which is all this
generates of modeling stuff I'm just
inching you there little by little so
what if I wanted to do a signaling
Paradigm where it's not the zero one
interval so for instance suppose I want
to specify a point on a 2d map or
something in higher Dimensions the
essence of the problem is exactly this
right now I have this point that's in my
head that for instance it's in uh R2 and
the posterior distribution is going to
be a posterior distribution over R2 I
still want to constrain the query point
that the computer provides how do I
think about this and what I want you to
remember
is uh we cannot do exactly what we did
in the 1D because if you remember this
whole thing about making sure that the
next input was independent involved
using a CDF shoving a random variable
into its own CDF right but a CDF what's
the output of a CDF it's always a number
between zero and one but remember I'm
trying to Signal something that's an R2
now
so hopefully you can appreciate that I
cannot just use the CDF trick so I have
to rethink about what was even happening
in the 1D case I had to think about it
differently in a way that can generalize
does that clear to everyone so this is
what we did before
but I'm using the CDF trick right
the output of a CDF is a number between
zero and one how can that apply if I'm
in R2 or something else right so what we
had to appreciate it took us a long time
to appreciate this that really what
we're doing is we're building a map
that's transforming a sample from the
posterior distribution into a sample
from the prior distribution that is the
essence of what we're doing because if
you stand back and you look at this
think about what this map is doing
so remember uh I have y's up until time
T minus one and with that I have the
posterior distribution right but then
ultimately what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to generate something so remember
I want the next input to be independent
of everything the decoder has seen so
far so if it's independent of everything
the decoder's seen so far it should just
be uniform zero one
so that means what I'm really doing is
I'm taking a sample from the posterior
distribution and transforming it into a
sample from the prior so I'm
transforming something from P to Q
right so really what we were doing
before was taking the posterior
distribution and building a map that's
that's building uh that's a
transformation from there to the prior
and these can be distributions and
arbitrary spaces once we realize this
and so that's how we can generalize this
uh to arbitrary Dimensions is that clear
everyone the essence of what we were
doing before is is what is here so I
always remember X is always just some
quantizer on that wct right to make sure
it has optimal capacity achieving input
but the key thing is I want WT to be um
you see there's this relationship
between WT and the original W right
right and uh and what is the key essence
of this map this map is transforming a
sample from the posterior distribution
to the prior distribution that's the
essence of what this is doing so it
turns out with that we can actually
generalize this right so uh uh you know
I I can imagine that it's something
about a map transforming a sample from
ptq when I Define p and Q appropriately
so once we realize this is you'll see we
thought about a formulation
um or generally the essence of how can I
construct a map
so that I can transform samples from one
distribution P to another q this is like
the plinkable board example if anyone is
familiar with that right the balls drop
out and you want to engineer the
locations of these little things so that
when the force of gravity drops these
down they come into this new shape right
here this is sort of the essence of what
we're trying to do and I argue that we
can actually solve many problems with
this in particular we can solve problems
in Bayesian inference in active learning
as well as generative modeling the last
thing I want to say is I hope you guys
can appreciate when I have that uh when
I do that query point and you're just
comparing to your query because everyone
appreciate that there's really an
instance of active learning right once
we look at it from that query
perspective so so in some sense we can
solve many problems with active learning
so
uh here's a statement uh uh from Michael
Jordan uh he said uh I think uh data
analysis can deliver inference at
certain levels of quality but we have to
be clear about what levels of quality we
have to put error bars around our
predictions and what he means right here
is suppose so this is like before deep
learning like you know for deep learning
really took off this is around 2014 or
the hottest thing since sliced Brad was
you know using convex optimization
algorithms to build map estimates right
and you know L1 regularizers and things
like this is everyone can anyone even
remember before deep learning what the
hottest thing was right compressed
sensing and all that so the essence of
what he's saying is suppose that you
have two posterior distributions the
green one and the blue one notice that
the map estimate for both of those is
the location of that red dot but the
green one has more uncertainty than the
blue one so he's saying it's
insufficient to just get you know we
need to think about the error bars how
do we do this in high Dimensions by the
way this wasn't Michael Jordan
basketball player Michael Jordan here UC
Berkeley so so shout out to UC Berkeley
once again okay so in the spirit of what
Michael Jordan said said you know how
can we think about this how can we think
about quantifying the full uncertainty
with respect to the posterior
distribution and um
just as an example a lot of things that
we do with Bayesian reasoning is we want
to minimize some loss function with
respect to a decision you know decision
variable uh but there's some latent
variable from which we have noisy
observations of right so this this whole
setup of you know achieving the Bayes
risk and whatnot and the high level
point is that um I can approximate this
conditional expectation if I could get
IID samples from the posterior right so
the idea here is a is an action all
right so if I take one action what is
going to be the loss the loss is with
respect to the latent variable but what
I've measured is y so in some sense for
optimal decision making I want to
minimize this conditional expectation uh
well if I had IAD samples from the
posterior they clearly I can approximate
this quite well
so
but I hope you can appreciate it in many
situations when we do Bayesian reasoning
we can sample from the prior easily it
might be a gaussian or a laplacian
something we can sample from uh easily
when can we build a map that can
transform samples from the prior into
samples from the posterior right and uh
if so then I can generate IAD samples
from the posterior another instance is
active learning and what I want you to
appreciate is all that stuff I talked
about with brain computer interfaces and
all that that's really just an instance
of active learning right because
um you guys remember what the canonical
example that Active Learning is like I
have a number between 1 and 20 in my
head right and and you uh you ask me a
question and maybe you hear it through a
noisy Channel you need to figure out
what's the sequence of questions that
you ask all right so the number between
1 and 20 is the W and then the question
that we ask is q and we know that
there's smart sequence of questions you
can ask and they're dumb sequence of
questions you can ask it's in essence
the same problem so I hope you can see
how this Maps Active Learning and then
the title of my talk I mentioned
generative modeling and the idea here
and I'll Showcase in just a moment is we
think about the essence of what
underlies the ideas of a gan
um I have IED samples I have a bunch of
pictures right pictures of cats pictures
of dogs or whatever it is and what I
would like to do is I would like to
build a generative model from which I
can generate new pictures from that so
if I take every picture and I take the
RGB values I treat that as a point R3 I
have a bunch of pixels if I have n
pixels then that's you know point in
Three N dimensional space the idea is
that if I can take those IID samples and
transform transform them for instance
into a a standard normal in Three N
dimensions then what I can do is I can
generate new samples
from a standard normal and three n
dimensions and go through the inverse
map and in principle I can generate new
pictures right so so hopefully everyone
can see that this is an instance of this
too so what I wanted to do was I have
like a Swiss army knife framework where
I have one problem formulation that can
solve all three of those problems and so
the idea is that suppose that I have uh
n samples that are IID from some
distribution p and I may not know it
and what I want to do is I want to
transform them to some distribution q
and to capture the essence of the
Bayesian inference problem suppose I
know the density of Q only up to a
normalization constant because we all
know in Bayesian reasoning in high
dimensions a lot of times we can't get
the denominator so suppose I only have
the density of Q up to a normalization
constant and a key assumption I'm going
to make is that Q is log concave and the
reason I say that is because in in many
of the instances it is so for instance
remember in posterior matching I want to
remember p
was the posterior distribution but then
Q was the prior and Q is like uniform
across the unit interval or the unit
square right so that clearly is log
concave if you think within the case of
Bayesian inference when is even just
getting an map estimate of Bayesian
inference a well-behaved problem well it
turns out when the posterior is locked
concave right so so I hope you can
appreciate is that there's you know you
know even solving simpler problems the
need for Q to be log concave is natural
and so my objective is to estimate a map
s to transform samples from P into
samples from Q
and so
one way we can think about this problem
is that there's this anchor queue that
we're trying to get to and we know what
Q is or at least we know it up to a
normalization constant uh we can ask
ourselves suppose I pick an arbitrary
map s
what would be the underlying P for which
s transformed P to Q again if you guys
remember undergrad probability right
suppose that s was well behaved suppose
for instance that it was uh monotonic
right then remember that there's a uh
the transformation of variable equation
right so the the density of P at U
induced by the map s is Q at s of U but
then the notion of length changed and
this is like S Prime of U if we were in
one dimension and more generally this
becomes a determinant of Jacobian and
higher dimensions
so one thing I'm doing right here is I'm
forcing my map to be the set of maps
that are monotonic okay and it turns out
without loss of generality I can do that
anyone here who knows a little bit of
optimal transport knows that if p and Q
have densities there always exists a map
that lies in this space that does that
and this is a famous result by a french
guy named brenier right they're always
just a map that's a gradient of a
strictly convex function so if it's the
gradient of a strictly convex function
then convexity means that the second
derivative information is not negative
so that means the Jacobian is positive
definite that basically means it's a
mono it's an increasing map so we can
always do that because of brainier okay
so what here's one so here's the idea
the idea is that there's this true s
star that links P to Q
if I pick an arbitrary s then this is
just the the you know the change of
variables formula from undergrad
probability so that's going to be some P
tooling that's induced by that assets
over there so since Q is anchored maybe
what I can do is vary across all S's and
I'm implicitly varying across all these
ptool these and wait until P20 is close
to p
so if you think about that for a moment
that's kind of the essence of Maximum
likelihood estimation
and what I mean by that is that when you
think about maximum likelihood
estimation I have IID samples X and
they're drawn from a class of densities
it's parameterized by a Theta remember
what I just did previously is I had a
class of densities that are
parameterized by this map s okay and as
I as I search over all of these or I
pick the one that maximizes the log
likelihood that's the same thing as
minimizing the negative log likelihood
keep in mind this isn't this is the you
know these are IED samples for p right
so this is the empirical expectation
which is approximately the same thing as
a true expected value I can add or
subtract anything that doesn't vary with
Theta so in particular I can put the log
of the prior in there so really what I'm
doing is a KL Divergence minimization
right so as we all know this is the
essence of ml estimation right the
essence of Maximum likelihood estimation
is minimizing the relative entropy
between the true p and the and the in
the P20 is parameterized by your Theta
so you know one way I could think about
this problem is doing that right so I
could try to do some ml estimation over
the space of monotonic maps right so all
I'm doing is I'm just rewriting what we
did for maximum likelihood estimation
and now going from here to here I'm just
using our change of variables variables
formula remember P tool the evaluate any
U is Q of s of U right and multiplied by
the determinant of the Jacobian so now
when I take the negative log I get this
right here and now here's where I hope
you can start to appreciate why I wanted
uh the the function to be log concave
so remember that Bernier told us that we
can always let the map s be uh um be the
gradient of a strictly convex function
which means the Jacobian is positive
definite do you guys remember from your
convex optimization class that the log
debt operator is always concave over the
space of positive definite matrices so
this object right here is always going
to be if this is concave then it's
negative right is convex so this object
is always convex in the space of the S's
and if Q is log concave that means the
negative log of q that s of X is going
to be convex so at least you know this
is a convex problem so this is how we
first started thinking about the problem
but if you think about the class of maps
if p is not close to Q then s
necessarily is going to be a very
non-linear map
so although this is a well-behaved
convex problem we start to play around
with this but if I wanted to come up
with some type of basis to transform
these Maps it's a very non-linear map
okay it's convex in the space of you
know you know in the space but how am I
really going to search through this you
know we're not sure so
started playing around on optimal
transport world and uh it turns out that
there's there's another way that you can
build a sequence of maps that transform
something from one distribution to
another and this is uh basically a long
driven Dynamics and so the high level
ideas uh if I you know suppose that to
have a system that's not in
thermodynamic equilibrium when it's in
equilibrium we know that it you know the
distribution corresponds to the
boltzmann distribution so let's imagine
that that corresponds to Q that's when
it's in equilibrium it's the boltzmann
distribution that's Q I can always take
q and represent it as a boltzmann right
without loss of generality I can do that
right okay
well remember we start off with ID
samples from P so that's almost imagine
like it's out of equilibrium and now I
want to watch what happens when it
starts to go back to equilibrium well
people know that that obeys the long
driven Dynamics right uh it's a
stochastic differential equation that
sort of describes what occurs and here's
a sort of discretization of it so so at
initial Time Zero it's a Time p and it's
basically converging and keep in mind
that this nabla on fee fee is the energy
function inside of the the boltzmann
distribution so this is a stochastic
different differential equation you know
discretized time
what's cool is that
um yeah so this is the continuous time
sort of version of what's happening this
is the sde of it there's a one-on-one
correspondence between so remember this
is like a generative statement about if
the sample Time Zero came from p and it
eventually is going to converge to
equilibrium equivalently you could think
about the distribution
of the samples right and how they're
evolving and they're evolving according
to a pde known as the folk or Planck
equation you guys don't need to know the
details of it but there's a one-to-one
correspondence so all the high level
conceptual thing I'm trying to do is I
want Q my anchor where I want you to end
up I'm going to represent that as a
boltzmann distribution the sample
started off with some P right and I'm
going to just let the laws of physics
bring them back into equilibrium
according to this equation and what's
nice is that it's a continuous Evolution
and so what that means that underneath
this the distribution at Time Zero was p
and it's a little by little moving and
it's moving towards q and if you
discretize time
then clearly it's a very small
infinitesimal change which means that
the underlying map going from P say 0 to
P1 when I dispertize time to P2 each of
those are infinitesimal changes they're
almost identity mappings they're
slightly you know they're slightly
non-linear mappings close to the
identity so maybe I can parametrize
these better
and so
something else that was cool that I
stumbled upon is this famous paper they
called jko uh because the the fir you
know the first character and the last
names ever the authored or jkno and so
this is a famous paper in the field of
optimal transport Theory variational
formulation of the focal Planck equation
and basically what they show is that
that evolution of the densities
obeys you can look at it differently and
the way you can think about it
is that I Define the wasserstein
distance which I hope many of us know
what it is it's a you know optimal
transport distance between distributions
and the high level idea is that when the
density is at some some time Point K you
know and it's evolving it's going to go
you know then it's going to go to time K
plus one we know that it's kind it's
kind of going towards the the uh the
boltzmann distribution it's moving
towards Q in what sense can we mean that
well what we mean by this is that um
so row Infinity is Q okay so row
Infinity is q and so what I want you to
do is I want you to to make the relative
entropy between where you are your next
step in queue to be smaller but I don't
want you to be too far away from where
you were previously and so this is this
is you know and then the limit as H
tends to zero this is exactly the
Dynamics of this right and and actually
the way this is written is that this is
a gradient Descent of the relative
entropy with respect to the Washington
distance and do people remember why this
in some sense might be a gradient
descent
if I have time I can draw it on the
board but um so when people think about
I'll just give you a hint right here
it's something called implicit gradient
descent so when you uh hold people over
there can see uh when you do gradient
descent the way you're typically thought
about it is I always forget the minus
and the plus right so if I'm trying to
minimize this function right
and I'm right here and I know that this
is the minimum so I say that uh X it's
time t plus one is going to be equal to
x t right and so notice if I'm at this
point right here that I want to go to
the left right but notice that the
derivative of the function is positive
so ends up being minus right some gamma
times F Prime evaluated at x t is
everyone familiar with that this is an
implicit scheme oh sorry this is an
explicit scheme you can build an
explicit scheme where you say x t plus
one equals x t plus gamma F Prime at
time X2 plus one x t plus one right here
and then you implicitly solve for x t
plus one and it turns out that
then I can go to this later it's a bunch
of math you what you can show is that
this is um you end up having just the
euclidean distance right here and this
right here is just the function that
you're minimizing it ends up being
exactly that okay so
uh yeah and so this becomes the focal
block equation so something else that's
nice is that um when Q is a lot of
concave I remember I want that if Q is a
log account K if it has a little extra
property it's a little more than log
concave if it's uh All Uniform log
concave which basically means that
um when you look at the um you know the
second derivative of information is
strictly basically strictly greater than
zero s compared to greater than or equal
to zero and the generalization of that
in higher Dimensions which means that
the um do you guys remember what this
means right this means if I take the
Hessian and I subtract off Lambda I then
that's a positive definite quantity
that's all that means so uh if that if
that holds it you get exponential
convergence in time so what this means
is if I build very small little uh
discretizations H then I you know I I
know that I'm that the the kale
Divergence is converging exponentially
fast and this is another famous result
in a in an optimal transport Theory so
what I want to see is if I do math on
this is anything cool happen and it
turns out luckily it does does so so
remember this is basically the
variational formulation of the focal
Planck equation by jko but remember I
don't care about the distributions I
care about the underlying maps and so uh
is there something I can say about the
maps and it's not too hard to see but
now suppose I build an objective
function over Maps where I have row time
K minus one this is the induced map by
that s remember that that that update
equation right here and this is
basically where you would be at the next
time step notice by the way that these
two things are in some sense reversed
but because the KO Divergence is uh um
invariant to to uh to a verbal
Transformations this and this are the
exact same thing
and and uh when I minimize over all
possible maps that are monotonic I'm
basically going to get this quantity so
it turns out this minimization problem
that minimization problem are in essence
the same thing but here I'm representing
it over Maps Okay so now what I wanted
to do is I want to look at this problem
over maps and think now remember all I
have is IED samples right I actually
don't have the distribution P but the
beauty is I can just you know
place this with taking IID samples from
this so just to remind ourselves
this is what we had from the previous
side and now what I'm doing is remember
that P20 I'm representing is Q of s of x
times log down I'm sorry times the debt
and I take the negative log and then I
still have this remaining term right
here which is just x minus s of x
squared and now the only thing I'm going
to do is I'm just going to replace this
with uh the empirical expectation with
respect to IID samples and the beauty is
that when Q is log concave I always get
convexity here because you see I have
negative log of Q remember log that is
always well behaved and this is just
quadratic in s
right so I get lock and cavity here but
what's also nice about this is that um
what's also nice about this is that now
I can parameterize these Maps like with
a basis or something with a bunch of
functions that maybe are almost the
identity with slight non-linearities
because remember on on discretizing uh
very very slowly so each each member row
K minus one and row K for small distant
organizations are very close to each
other which means that the map is almost
the identity map with slight
non-linearities so I do that and then uh
you know so one way I do this is
something called the polynomial chaos uh
and the reason that we do this uh yeah
so you see you have the identity
operator plus you have some of your
non-linear terms and a high level what I
can do is all the polynomial chaos is
it's a set of maps that are based
orthogonal with respect to some
distribution right and so if I have
information about the distribution that
I'm trying to get to I can get there so
I had convexity but something else
that's nice for instance when you use
the polynomial chaos is that log
concavity of Q implies selection sub
exponential Tails which means that these
are dense in L2 of P which basically
means as you use more and more of these
you actually are representing yeah yeah
you know it's quite obvious what that
means right that uh and the limit is I
use more and more maps I can actually uh
uh get uh the true optimal map
so then the next step is just some
details for you guys but you know you
know since part of this is about privacy
and security I thought you guys might
like this because uh Vince poor has
written papers on solving 80mm problems
and maintaining differential privacy we
didn't do this but I think there's an
opportunity to do this that if you stand
back you look at this problem I have
these IED samples with these xi's but I
have a common map s that I'm searching
over so in some sense looks like a
problem like this right and if people
know anything about admm this begins to
fit the framework of edmm in the essence
of the admm problem is something like
this where I have f of x plus G of e
subject to the constraint that ax plus b
z equals c so if you remember what we
can do is we can build a penalized
lagrangian where we have our original
lagrangian but we add this quadratic
term right here and what this allows us
to do this allows us to do coordinate
descent and guarantee that uh um we'll
get the optimal solution so if anyone
has played around with ADM there's a
saying all men are created equal but not
really there's all these weird things
that you might have to do where you have
to introduce on auxiliary variable
really carefully and yada yada yada so
we introduced some auxiliary variables
um each of these WIS have to be this
common consensus consensus variable B
and we introduce these other variables
associated with the jacobians and other
things and uh when we do this we get
this is what our penalized lagrangian
looks like and
um
what's very nice about this is that all
three of these terms now are quadratic
and they have closed form solution
updates and some of these you only need
to solve once with linear algebra and
once you solve it once you never have to
do it again so using this you know all
men are created equal but not really
analogy when we parameterize the maps
this way the set of updates for ADM are
basically every single one is a closed
form linear algebra update except for
one and this one is a uh a a a point
estimation problem almost like solving
an map estimation problem in just D
Dimensions right so it's just you see
you have negative log Q right plus uh
quadratic penalty so it's just like
solving some type of map estimation
problem and what you end up doing is you
end up solving each of these across
separate nodes and then you do your
consensus updates and we actually
implemented all this in AWS and remember
this is you know yeah is like 2010
something around there oh no sorry
2017 something and then we were doing
this and so what's really cool is that
each one of these nodes is just doing a
linear algebra update solving One D
dimensional convex optimization problem
integrate everything together and you
can do this and
um
random face and you don't have to do it
on a chip
uh well I was thinking the more General
problem so even generative modelings
almost like the Gan problem but but
something where we can guarantee you
know theoretical properties but how it
behaves uh what's also nice about this
is when you use gpus you get performance
improvements right with the number of
dimensions
so yeah yeah so remember the number of
Dimensions that we're in that this is
the beauty so yeah this is the statement
about all men who created equal but not
really when we formulate the ADM problem
this way all these are linear algebra
updates Matrix inverses and One D
dimensional convex optimization problem
and it's very similar to a Brock's map
yeah but that is really appropriate
because because there's uh you know that
there's a
there are various um
works on debiasing the discrete time jko
because this three-time jpo is biased he
does not have the right distribution
using procs and splitting methods you
can actually come up with various ways
of doing it so I wasn't aware of that so
you're saying uh well that um that might
be implicitly what we're doing because
this is I mean the proximal operators
underneath all this right yeah I mean
this is very very just reasonable work
spots you know that like cold you know
last year I'm not aware of that so
that's why it's good to have Max here
students remember I told you guys
there's a walking encyclopedia so uh
yeah so the results for the simulation
so what we end up doing is so high level
idea is now we're composing a bunch of
maps so this is kind of like a deep
Network in some sense we're composing a
bunch of non-linear Maps but how we're
building each one is different we're
using convex optimization so when I
compose all of these together I'm
basically doing that that long driven
Dynamics or only focus equation so
suppose I start off in two dimensions
and I have a um I hope this thing is
going to run it's supposed to be
animating right now sorry if it will
I don't know why it's not oh there it is
it going now yeah so it starts off as
like this bimodal almost like a mixture
of gaussians and remember all I have are
IAD samples one beautiful thing about
this result is I don't need to know
anything about the Distribution on p as
long as they're IID because remember I
want to capture the Gan problem where I
just have these images right I want to
generate new images and the only thing
I'm saying is I want to sequentially
build a composition of maps so that when
I compose them together the aggregate is
going towards a standard normal gaussian
as you can kind of see there and I think
you can see the points and they start
off as kind of bimodal and these are the
the transformations of the points and
you see that they're they're being
transformed into a gaussian block
so some results with this framework in
terms of Bayesian inference we were able
to address that problem so here are IID
samples from the prior and we transform
them to ample IID samples from the
posterior this is like a 95 you know
window with respect to the prior and
this is the 95 credibility interval if
people are familiar with that it's
basically the equivalent of the
confidence interval when you're doing
Beijing inference uh we we know we
carefully engineered a scenario where
the map estimate for the green and the
blue are the same paying homage to
Michael Jordan here and so this is um
uh the high level ideas actually you
have a small number of samples uh uh you
have this right here here's where you
have a lot of samples and so here's what
your credibility interval looks like and
here's what it looks like here and
notice that the the map estimate for
both is the exact same so in some sense
what I'm able to do now is I'm trying to
go back to that 2014 statement of
Michael Jordan and now we have our quote
unquote error bars right we have our 95
credibility interval one thing that's
cool by the way is with this if you have
the 95 percent interval with respect to
the prior all you do is you take every
point there and you apply the map to it
and you get your 95 credibility interval
which is cool uh we also show that
basically you can attain the Bayes risk
and we compared our approach to using a
Markov chain Monte Carlo approach and
you see that we're achieving achieving
the base risk faster right so it's not
surprising because they're IID samples
um in terms of this Active Learning
setup you know I won't I won't uh sort
of bore you with this but this was the
the brain computer interface stuff I was
interested in so does everyone remember
this picture of Shannon right so imagine
now I have rather than a binary
symmetric Channel I have like a four
input Channel where uh and it's
symmetric as well uh we can just
simulate what occurs right here and uh
what ends up happening is end up zooming
in so this is the point of interest is
where that that the arrow is and you're
zooming in on areas that have higher
probability and you sequentially uh
signal that's what it looks like with
respect to that spelling but we also um
wanted to do something like specifying a
point on a 2d map so we did something
kind of cool where we assume now suppose
that I have two people with common
knowledge
and so imagine there's two people and
they're distributed two different parts
of the World Imagine it's like I'm like
a crime scene or something right and
they both witnessed that crime scene but
they're now in two different locations
so they both have this common piece of
knowledge in their head can I show
different questions to both of them and
eventually zoom in on this this is the
high level idea and so we basically were
able to use all this stuff with optimal
transport stuff and the wall Ron variety
and we're able to engineer
to interfaces for both of the people so
we actually did this in collaboration
with people University of Puerto Rico so
one of my trainees in San Diego and the
other one is in Puerto Rico and the high
level idea is if you if you want to
signal to a forum input scheme is it
clear to everyone that one person can
can signal are you to the left or the
right of this line and the other one
signals if you're to the left or right
of the other going line one going you
know uh from the Northwest to the
southeast another one going from the
southwest to the Northeast so one person
has shown one of these lines the other
one is showing the other and aggregately
when they cooperate they can do it so
literally This Guy's in San Diego This
Guy's in Puerto Rico and they end up
sequentially
what ends up happening is the query
point is changing so there's an instance
of active learning and as they're
signaling over time the query point is
changing and you basically are telling
me what location it's in and I can kind
of show you how the posterior
probabilities are changing so up front
the posterior with no information is
just uniform after a couple of points of
signaling it looks like this it looks
like this and so you can see the
posterior is Contracting right it's
becoming more and more narrow oh yes sir
so just wondering so this is the analogy
where we're taking up the series
yes I can yeah there's a in our paper uh
proceedings like Tripoli 2017 we talk
about that but uh an interesting Quest
yeah so when we have like a um
a four input Channel or a finite input
Channel there's an analogy to that but
but the question of how you do that more
generally with respect to this query
point we don't know if that's been fully
solved but for the four input scheme
we're able to do it
um so that's something that's still I'm
not sure it's fully solved it's an
interesting mathematical question so one
high level point I want to make here is
that this famous quote by David
Blackwell that I like shout out UC
Berkeley you guys see the theme right is
uh you know I'm not interested in doing
research and I never have been I'm
interested in understanding which is
quite different often to understand
something you have to work it out
yourself because no one has done it and
the key point is that we originally were
really interested in solving this brain
comparative interface problem with
feedback in one dimension we're able to
leverage horstein and shave its and
feeder but going to higher Dimensions
you can't just use that CDF trip so we
had to really kind of take one step back
and rethink what was going on in one
dimension and then map it to more
dimensions and that's how we ended up
with the optimal transport and then we
realized well wait a minute if we can do
this we can solve a lot of problems so
then we got into the Bayesian inference
and the generative modeling so it also
started with China in some sense this
quote by David Blackwell
so
then lastly for generative modeling this
was the title of my talk
so remember for generative modeling
suppose I have IID samples from this
distribution p and this might be like
images or whatever hell this is and the
structure of this is really awkward and
bizarre if I can transform these samples
into samples from a well-behaved
distribution like a gaussian
uh yeah so if I can take a map s that
transforms the distribution of the data
into a standard gaussian then what I can
do is I can generate new samples from Q
and shove them through the inverse map
and now I have new IID samples from p
and I see yes it's a generative modeling
one thing that's nice about optimal
transport by the way is you might ask is
s inverse always exists the answer is
yes brenier there always exists a map
right that is uh uh that that that's
monotonic if it's monotonic and clearly
it has an inverse right so another
benefit that we get is we get the
inverse map for free uh using this
brainier Optimum transport Viewpoint
um so one thing we're able to do is
everyone knows the emness problem right
so 784 dimensions and so these were the
IID samples and then we generated new
samples here you can see they kind of
reflect that so so uh um and I'm not
trying to directly compete with deep
learning algorithms I'm sure that again
can do it better especially with all the
all of the the new advances but the one
thing that I think is interesting is is
conceptually uh we can at least prove
things about what's happening it's a
sequence of steps Each of which is
convex and it's building upon the
framework of some of this optimal
transport stuff and so just uh yeah
going to your question about the
dimension of the lease that's polynomial
and D linear in the number of samples uh
what's nice also remember it's backwards
compatible with point estimation methods
because remember there's all this stuff
about building distributed you know
Point estimation schemes uh um so it's
backwards compatible with all that and
what's also nice is it you know sort of
builds this this connection with
computational fluid mechanics and
laundry methods for
um non-equilibrium thermodynamics then
obviously convex optimization so
so yeah this is uh some fun stuff that
we were doing and uh uh being respectful
of the times 9 58. maybe we can take a
question or two but yeah
sure so yes great talk
um I think what you're doing with the
generative modeling is very similar to
diffusion models absolutely right
absolutely and I think the fusion models
have actually
now are
outperforming games and so I'm wondering
basically whether to draw from here and
actually improve diffusion yeah so we
published this paper in 2019 we were
starting to see some of those diffusion
papers and whatnot and we reference some
of them in our work so we think there's
a very close connection so the diffusion
stuff is also building upon focusing
type of stuff and the key thing that we
did those remember is we built the GTO
variational interpretation of the focus
one so that we can leverage Quebec City
when we get log concavity at the cube
and uh
uh uh I wouldn't be surprised if other
people are doing similar things you know
one thing that's true that this is like
a red ocean pollution you know Cutthroat
competition is just something that she
seems to Ocean bloody right it's like
all the Deep learning stuff right I like
to play in this other space
uh so one of the things that I noticed
that after we published our work other
people are doing related work but they
were not citing us but what can you do
so I I think there might be some overlap
but I don't care I think this was fun
this was cool publish a paper and
graduated my students but without
question I've seen a lot of diffusion
stuff happening in common I think this
his regularization by that KL term it's
not it wasn't done in the original
diffusion models this is where their
noises cannot be tuned as well sometimes
yeah I think there are like multiple
formulations okay and I think the recent
ones are actually similar so they might
yeah because jko is so popular now I've
seen it in the Deepwater community so so
the southern there's a there's a fairly
definitive paper
from Eric Van tonight at NYU called
stochastic interpolence but basically
just gives you
a unifying view of all these things as
stochastic control in the space of
measures yeah controllability and by the
way so you know Roger Brockett passed
away recently yeah he may have had one
of the first papers on this when he had
a paper called control optimal control
the blue Bill equation interesting
so we've got let's nerd out over this on
break yes yeah
uh well it's wonderful to see everybody
for the people who showed up late Aaron
I'm sure you're my first line
hopefully by the way Aaron uh my first
slime the best short right yeah your
best work so I haven't seen you in a
while here so uh family has grown so we
got a six-year-old boy and a 20 month
old girl it should pop up in just a
moment
um that's the most important most
important result yeah so well it's not
uh let me see if I can do this
so uh yeah
so uh with that uh let's go to break and
let's talk more
[Applause]